This is an age where disruptions
are taking place at such a rapid pace.
Where the company can go from leading
to bleeding at the blink of an eye.
>> It's really about
designing to be agile.
Designing to anticipate the unknown.
[MUSIC]
Almost all solutions to problems out
there have a technology base to it.
And it is the CIO who
has to be leading the charge in terms
of coming up with innovative solutions.
The CIO program is geared towards CIOs
leveraging technology to drive change
across organizations.
What we want to do is to have everyone
see the CIO not as a cost center but
as a solution center.
>> From strategic vision development,
innovation, scaling excellence,
this program will make me a better leader.
>> This program exposes CIOs to
the cutting edge tools that
are available out there.
For example, design thinking or behavior
design, to cutting-edge frameworks,
concepts, best practices out there.
>> When we brainstorm,
we put up an idea and
who ever can shoot down the idea
first is the genius in the room.
And through design thinking,
really picked up some great ways
to do brainstorming better.
How do we get more rapid
in terms of prototyping and
testing things rather than spending
six months kind of building something,
only to get the feedback
after we launch it?
>> Something as simple as understanding
that we make decisions generally 95%
of the time based on emotion and instinct.
It's very fundamental and
will absolutely carry value going forward
in probably all aspects of my life.
It's the all-star content
from the GSB no doubt, and
then on top of it, it's in Silicon Valley.
In one week you really do get to
kind of capture the essence of what
it's like here.
>> One of the great aspects of this
program is that we have time for
discussion so that others who have similar
problems can learn from one another.
>> It is a completely immersive week.
[LAUGH] And it's joyfully intense.
>> Changes that are going to take
place in the future in organizations
in the marketplace are going
to be led by CIO's.
>> I think all of these
skills will allow more and
more CIOs to sit at the table with other
C-level executives as being really
critical in driving
innovation in a company.